what's going on guys this is rob and
this video is sponsored by omaze which
we'll talk about here in a minute but a
lot of you guys really enjoyed the video
that we did where we talked about kang
not getting a whole lot of build up and
how that could potentially be an issue
for the mcu in terms of him being like a
big overarching villain and it wasn't
really designed to be a griping session
but not really looking to tear the mcu
down but what i wanted to do here was
focus on what i have observed in terms
of potentially being another problem in
the mcu and again really look at this
more from things they could be doing as
opposed to like the mcu sucks right like
that kind of a thing so when it comes to
the marvel cinematic universe there is
kind of a reason why this is happening
and so i do understand it to a degree
and a lot of it is really based on the
fact that like disney and marvel have
just now gotten the x-men and fantastic
four properties which really includes a
lot of this stuff but now that they have
them
there is a massive issue they can
correct from the mcu and this is
basically the space opera before we get
into this i do want to talk about omaze
and again thank you to them for
sponsoring this video so for those of
you guys who have never heard of omaze
these guys are really really awesome
what they have here is basically a
really sustainable approach to
fundraising which means the various
non-profits that they're fundraising for
can in turn focus more on ensuring that
those funds go to their communities in a
way that benefits them the most as
opposed to focusing on fundraising so
what they have going on right now is a
campaign where you can enter for a
chance to win a tesla model x plat i
have a model 3 performance i'm probably
going to upgrade to a model x plaid
somewhere along the line just
consolidate both my vehicles into that
but tesla's are amazing and being able
to enter for your chance to win one of
these is awesome because your funds are
going to support a charitable cause so
the first one of these is give power
which is currently on a mission to
basically bring 2.2 billion people
around the world access to safely
managed drinking water which is a very
much needed thing in the world right now
the second one is 501c3 uh which really
has this mission of bringing the idea of
a new type of nonprofit to like younger
people right it's focused more on energy
food water and shelter and i know a lot
of younger people now are far more
active than you all were when i was
younger uh really non-profit charities
things like that weren't as big of a
thing back then as they are now so it's
great to see companies like omaze
offering their own
innovative take on the idea of
charitable causes so make sure you check
the link in the description to enter for
your chance to win the tesla model x
plaid as well as supporting give power
and 501 c3 again the url for that is
omaze.com
geek culture but let's get back into the
video so right now the marvel cinematic
universe and a lot of this is built on
the fact that like the first 10 years
just focused on the threat of thanos and
that was basically it albeit i would say
there were a lot of missed opportunities
here the marvel cinematic universe
largely struggles with the same thing
that marvel struggled with marvel comics
anyway for like the first 40 years and
that's the fact that in marvel comics
from like the 60s running all the way up
to like the 2000s
there wasn't really much of a space
opera there was but there wasn't it's
one of the reasons why stories like
infinity gauntlet or infinity war or
infinity crusade were just like great
stories because they gave us this sort
of aspect of space that you didn't
normally even see but even like secret
wars in 1984 was fairly limited i mean
it was like a bunch of different people
some of whom were from space but they
were fighting on like a makeshift
hodgepodge world created by the beyonder
and then ultimately doctor doom stole
everybody or stole the beyonder's power
and swore unfolded blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah yada yada
the thing about this is that for for
those like 40 or 50 years in marvel the
idea was that basically you just had
characters who would go to space
occasionally and there were some
characters who were already in space
sometimes it was stories about richard
ryder who also went by the name nova the
first version of noma sam alexander is
my favorite he's just young and he's
amazing i love him as a character other
times it was like the silver surfer or
it might have been uh quasar who at the
time was wendell vaughn although i think
right now it's phyla vel the thing about
this is that you basically just saw
these stories where it was they were
almost all independent of each other
sometimes they would cross over but not
very often instead it would be a story
about quasar or it'd be a story about
silver surfer or story about nova uh and
then you might have things where like
star-lords introduced but the way that
he was originally introduced it was
totally wiped clean in the mid-2000s and
the reason why i say that is while you
did have again these kind of crossover
space based stories
all of this changed in the mid 2000s
with a guy named dan adnan and he was a
writer in marvel comics who basically
wrote a story called annihilation and
for like 10 years this guy literally
spearheaded just this huge expansion of
the space-faring escapades in marvel
comics and so like the formation of the
guardians of the galaxy albeit the one
in the movies was actually the one built
by bendis but uh the formation of the
guardians of the galaxies and all that
kind of stuff right all of that's dan
adam annihilation annihilation conquest
which those of you guys who never read
comics annihilation conquest is
basically a story where ultron tries to
conquer the universe he possesses adam
warlock at one point it had some cool
moments it wasn't as good as
annihilation but it had some cool
moments right things like thanos
imperative and all that kind of stuff
right while dan abnett didn't write
everything he basically led the charge
and planned everything and it was really
really cool because you got stories like
war of kings and realm of kings and
different things like that it was really
really great but the mcu doesn't
necessarily have that and again a lot of
that is really just predicated on the
fact that like the first 10 years were
focused on the threat of thanos
gathering the infinity stones and the
inevitability of what we knew to be the
moment where thanos was going to blink
out half the life in the universe but
now that we're done with that this is a
great opportunity to expand on things
and that's why having the fox properties
that were sold by marvel in like the
mid-2000s or at least the movie rights
anyway in the mid 90s rather that's why
this is such a great thing because what
this means is a lot of the space-faring
stuff that we could see
could be done by the fantastic four and
it wouldn't be overly difficult to do
but it wouldn't be overly hard to do all
you have to do is like reform shield and
just say okay because of like this giant
space god that's basically half emerged
from the earth which nobody really seems
to talk about at all or the fact that
thanos blinked out half the life in the
universe or whatever there's obviously
massive threats out there in space so we
need a team on earth who can go into
space and investigate that stuff and so
you get reed you get susan you get ben
you get johnny they get on some
spaceship they go into space and they're
immediately hit by cosmic rays and they
end up their their ship goes defunct
they crash land on earth and then what
do you know reid richards can stretch
and susan storm can make force fields
and make herself invisible and johnny
storm can set himself on fire and become
as hot as the sun and ben grimm's just
like a walking talking crack rock and
that's it right it's just like okay cool
like we have a fantastic four now
awesome right and then like from there
it's like let's go back into space and
then they just start going and exploring
things uh the x-men bring in the shiar
empire which is cool because right now
in the marvel cinematic universe all we
have are the cree and the scroll and
from the captain marvel movie all we
know is that they've just been like
waging war against each other for a
while and like the scrolls have
basically been losing and they are in
effect just refugees trying to find like
safe havens so they can live and not be
wiped out by the by the cree race
themselves how that translates into the
secret invasion tv show i don't entirely
know maybe it's just one of those things
we're like hey humanity uh thanks for
giving us a place to crash we're gonna
conquer your world now thanks peace you
know and that's basically it i have no
idea that's gonna be the case in the
comics it was because their world was
destroyed and basically they saw earth
is like the best place to inhabit
because the illuminati were basically
screwing with the scrolls and so because
of this i mean there's a little more
that goes into it than that but as cool
as those races are they have nothing on
the shiar empire because the shia empire
much like the cree and the scroll rule
like an entire section of the universe
right like they rule like a a full-on
galaxy the cree have their galaxy the
the scrolls have their galaxy the badoon
who we've only really seen reference and
kind of talked about and seen a few of
them in in like the guardians of the
galaxy films we don't really know how
far-reaching they are but in the comics
they have their own galaxy you've got
the dire race who have their own galaxy
like there's maybe there's like seven
different races each of whom rule their
own galaxies and we'll talk about the
significance of that here in a second
but the shia empire is amazing because
where the scrolls are just like a race
like a singular race and it expanded out
from scrollos into like the rest of
their galaxy and with a cree or a
singular race that had expanded out from
the planet hala into the rest of the
galaxy the shia empire is actually an
amalgamation of races that the shia
empire is led by the main shia race
themselves which look very similar to
birds or they're kind of modeled
afterbirds to a degree they're more
avian than they are like traditional
human but in effect what they do is they
travel around from like world to world
and they conquer it and then they bring
it into the service of the shia empire
as a whole and the reason why they do
this is because
it's basically a smarter deal right it's
a smarter thing to do because there are
more technologically advanced races out
there right so it's better to have an
empire composed of a bunch of different
races than have an empire composed of a
singular race and so what this did is it
also brought in something called the
imperial guard and the imperial guard is
legit i'll tell you right now even if
they bring the imperial guard in and
they like nerf them down right they
reduce them down in terms of like power
and danger from the comics to the mcu
there's still no team that's been
introduced in the marvel cinematic
universe that could go toe-to-toe with
the shia imperial guard we're of course
leaving out obvious you know obvious
things like doctor strange or like
scarlet witch or something like that but
like the traditional avengers team so
like thor incredible hulk iron man
captain america black widow hawkeye they
would get absolutely destroyed by the
imperial guard and probably just by
gladiator himself right gladiator is
what's called a strontium that's his
race he's basically an allegory for
superman and in fact he was modeled off
of superboy when he was originally
created this guy is a beast right this
guy took on juggernaut by himself like
the guy's an absolute hoss right he is
enough to be able to take on thor and
the incredible hulk how long that fight
between himself the incredible hulk
would go on i don't fully know because
the incredible hulk has infinite
strength and gladiator does not but the
point that i'm making here is this guy
by himself is an absolute monster you
add in the rest of the imperial garden
and almost nobody would stand a chance
they could take out thanos right now
from there you start moving into teams
like the annihilators right the
annihilators were a crazy powerful team
silver surfer vader ray bill who for
those of you guys don't know beta ray
bill was the first person in marvel
comics to be able to lift the hammer of
thor and he's basically been a massive
ally of thor ever since he's
crazy powerful he's just an amazing
character um let's see it had uh wendell
vaughn's quasar and then like ron and
the accuser i mean literally this team
is powerful enough to take on all comers
the only people who would be able to
overcome the annihilators this is
legitimately speaking the only people
who would be able to overcome the
annihilators would be obvious trump
cards like thanos with the infinity
gauntlet and the upper level cosmic
entities but like galatus he would fall
before the power of the annihilators
largely because of silver surfer and his
his abilities with the power cosmic
because all he has to do is just channel
that power cosmic and everybody else
sure i guess galactus could take it away
from him but he never does right so just
based on that like the annihilators are
a ridiculously dangerous team and that's
just to name a few right on top of that
then you have like just individual
characters that would be really really
interesting phyla vel's quasar the idea
of like the quantum bands the mega bands
look like what uh miss marvel has in the
miss marvel tv show that's coming up
whether or not that's actually true i'm
not really sure but as soon as i saw
that i was like those look like mega
bands to me right it looks like what's
happening there is all these different
forms of technology right like shane
cheese ten rings and all that kind of
stuff like it you you could argue and to
me it looked like stuff that belonged to
the inhumans the biggest bigger issue
you have to contend with there is like
according to like the post-credit scene
of of shang chi there's nothing there at
least as far as that technology that's
recognizable uh especially when it comes
to like space-faring stuff unless of
course with captain marvel being a
member of the cree and the cree being a
group that initially created the
inhumans if records of all of that stuff
was expunged so basically she doesn't
know they exist because as far as the
cree race is concerned all the history
was erased so there's nothing for her to
compare it again so that's entirely
possible right i mean we know from all
the comics the cree were the ones who
created the inhumans in the first place
right they were just considered a failed
project and all evidence of the of the
inhumans were erased by the kree supreme
intelligence so there's a there's that
possibility there but the point that i'm
making is that whenever it comes when it
comes to the space-faring escapades adam
warlock and people like that there's so
much you can do there and so i don't
know about you guys but i will say that
that ever since the ending
of avengers in game right um a lot of
what we've gotten so far seems to be
just kind of interim content like i love
spider-man no way home it was great and
it was amazing to find out it was
basically the the third movie in an
origin truly trilogy for tom hall and
spider-man i loved that and i'm really
really looking forward to doctor strange
too and i love to see what comes out of
like the loki tv show the falcon and
winter soldier was cool i guess and like
you know and and like the other shows
that we're getting right largely kind of
just seem to be filler content until we
get to like the next big thing right
which hopefully we end up getting which
may or may not be kang but what i'm
saying is that while i wouldn't argue
the mcu was growing stale at the moment
i would argue
it's only a matter of time before it
does if this isn't necessarily something
that they feed into that they tap into
that they kind of give us exposure to
with like the various gods that exist
out there thor love and thunder may very
well give us that because gore the god
butcher traveled around the universe
killing every god he could find on every
planet
everywhere i mean the it was it was nuts
like literally him and like the
all-black necro sword it was just him
killing everything and so this is a
great potential or a great chance or
opportunity for the marvel cinematic
universe even if it's only in cameos to
give us other things that exist out
there right say for example and this
this is something to keep in mind if
over the course of thor love and thunder
you end up having a moment where they
reference the fact that gore the god
butcher had killed shara and kiethri
those two names right there those are
the gods of the shia empire the shia
empire exists in the mcu right just like
that if gore the god butcher killed
klubben and slugert those are the gods
of the scroll race i know their names
sound weird but like those are the gods
of the scroll race right so it's like
okay cool like that's how they're
building up right how they're building
up and they're expanding on those things
so again not really a griping session
here it's just something i've observed
there's a lot of potential and focusing
on or at least bringing in space-faring
escapades into the marvel cinematic
universe it's only a matter of how they
do it but it would be great to see again
a lot of the stuff that was done here
the annihilators specifically was based
on previous knowledge of characters who
already existed ronnie accuser is dead
so there's no way he'd be part of the
annihilators silver surfer has not been
introduced yet adam warlock exists we
simply just haven't seen him yet last we
saw he was in a in a cocoon right and
that's basically it he presumably
emerged somewhere along the line and if
not will probably emerge in uh guardians
three or four four somewhere along those
i still say those are two sides of the
same movie right like infinity war and
avengers in game that those movies will
basically in some form or fashion
support each other like adam warlock
will likely appear in both i don't know
if that's the case or not uh but you
know a lot of those characters like beta
ray bill we saw like a statue of his
head on like sakhar people are saying
that's the case he's a corbinite but
he's also a unique looking corbinite so
again maybe maybe that was him maybe
that wasn't him i don't know but the
important thing here is that a lot of
these characters that will that could be
a part of the greater mcu as far as
space faring escapades haven't
necessarily been introduced yet
but i have to believe this is part of
the plan and if it's not that presents a
huge problem so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
right do you want to see more space
faring stuff
and is the stuff on earth kind of
growing
a little stale and if we do where do you
think we'll see the greatest expansion
of of space-based content in the mcu do
you think it's guardians 3 do you think
it's eternals 2 which will hopefully be
both a love letter and an apology for
eternals 1 do you think that it'll be in
thor love and thunder where do you think
we'll see a lot of this stuff up with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end again thank you to omaze
for sponsoring this video make sure you
guys check the link to the omaze
campaign down in the description and i
will catch you all later
peace